لقد كنت تتوقع قبل أسبوعين فقط
أن
يموت باغوسيان أو أنه سيكون هناك
انقلاب ثانٍ بحلول نهاية العام. ما
رأيك في التوقيت هنا إذا
كان بوتين وراء هذا البئر
أعني مرة أخرى على  إذا افترضنا أن
بوتين كان وراء ذلك، ويبدو أنه
لا توجد قوة في روسيا يمكنها
فعل ذلك خارج نطاق
تفويض بوتين، فإن
السؤال الوحيد هو لماذا حدث ذلك بهذه السرعة،
أعني السبب وراء ناقشنا في هذا البرنامج
بعض الأمور  قبل أسابيع يجب على
بوتين أن ينتقم للقضاء على السبق المحايد
أه بمجرد أن
وصفه بالتاجر لأنه بخلاف ذلك
سيفقد القدرة على الحكم بقسوة لا
ترحم المشكلة الوحيدة في
التوقيت هي أنه حدث
بسرعة كبيرة جدًا حدث قبل أن يتمكن بوتين
من
تدمير تأثير البريجوسيان بشكل أساسي في
أفريقيا، تدمير تأثير
التقدم على قوات فاغنر المتبقية
وأعتقد أن هذا له علاقة
بالضبط بأفريقيا، أعني في
الأسبوع الماضي شهدنا الكثير من التصعيد في
القتال العميق بين وزارة الدفاع والقوات المسلحة.
بوتين والكرملين من
جهة والبريغوسيان من جهة أخرى على
جوجل احتفظوا بالسيطرة على بعض
الأسواق الأكثر ربحًا في أفريقيا على
مالي على جمهورية أفريقيا الوسطى في
الواقع كان البريغوسيان في أفريقيا
اليومين الماضيين وكان في الطريق  عدت من
أفريقيا في محاولة للاحتفاظ بالسيطرة على
مالي وعدم التنازل عن السيطرة
لوزارة الدفاع وأعتقد أن
هذا التصعيد في الاهتمام
بأفريقيا هو الذي عجل باتخاذ الإجراءات
ضد بريجوسيا